welcome back to the iced coffee hour my
name is brandon turner from bigger
pockets here on the show and uh we're
going to talk about how this show's made
what dollar 73 from adsense in the last
year and a half a dollar seventy
seventy three right how'd you come up
with that number uh i mean i figured
it's not like a two dollar show but it's
not like a dollar show so it's somewhere
in the middle 1.73 yeah okay well you're
off okay buy a lot how much how much did
it make so far 133 000. that's what we
made so you're oh wow white house all
right about a 133 thousand dollars off
one couple decimal points that's not too
bad that's not it's around in here
well thank you so much for coming on
we're really excited to have you here
because uh you are like the real estate
house hacking guru like you are you are
the mecca when it comes to uh real
estate owning rental property house
hacking cash flow like everything
when people think of it they think of
you generally you have 3 000 units so
far that you rent out yeah which is
insane yeah and you've been crazy and
you moved to hawaii and you're basically
just living it up there
i'm doing a little bit living it up i'm
doing some uh i got two kids so you're
living it up as much as you can live it
up so i surf uh i could pretend to surf
and uh you know do the jogging on the
beach kind of thing trying to live that
cliche hawaii life that's good too bad
and we also before and real quick are we
recording yes because i never told you
yeah
i have done entire interviews where
we've forgotten always a nervous wreck
yeah interview like a celebrity one
camera
it was terrible like it was terrible
who was it i can't remember it was
somebody like a like a youtube kind of
guy like a camera you didn't record and
it was like 30 minutes in we're like oh
i'm so sorry but were they cool with
that yeah they were like cool with it
did you just redo it i made it yeah we
just we just did it over oh it was jim
quick uh jim quit you know him a famous
author he's like written millions that
sold billions of books but yeah jim
quick uh
brain guy he's all about brain stuff
anyway yeah it was like 30 minutes in we
realized we didn't hit through my worst
nightmares i think it is i think
everyone would understand because they
worry about themselves i know yeah i
worry so much so that if it happened to
me i'd be like all right well you know
how would i want to be treated just do
it again yeah it's that thought of like
also you're like what do i like when i
realized it all of a sudden i was like
oh no no no no that's the worst feeling
he's just like talking i was like what
do i do do i do i tell him do i just
wing it and be like
try to do you stop at midnight that's
the hardest thing yeah yeah so it was
speaking of which i know we're going off
at a tangent here i had that happen once
with him i flew all the way to detroit
remember yeah
so i did on my second channel the graham
stefan show did a reaction to this guy
alex pardo the video got a million views
in like a week and so i flew to detroit
to confront him in person
so the entire show and they went with me
kevin on this trip so the entire trip
was centered around just going for him
with this one interview this one
afternoon recorded the whole video
got back to the hotel room we're done it
went perfect and uh
the audio didn't record the entire time
it was just
nothing and so at 7 pm i called him back
and i'm like hey i'm so sorry can we do
it again oh and he was cool with it he's
like yeah sure so we filmed it again the
second time and it was just fine yeah
but yeah it sucks when it happens now
i'm like most like backup backup backup
yeah five different things yeah this
gotta work and still i've screwed it
okay well anyway anyway we also have
some drama to cover that you're no
longer going to be with bigger pockets
so yeah we'll save that we'll save that
towards the end all right but let's
start off from the very beginning how
did you get started before owning 3 000
properties how much does that make by
the way do you know every every month oh
that's how much is it i mean if our
average figure average rent around 500
dollars because there are a lot of
mobile home parks sure right so if you
figure whatever 500 i'm not a math guy
500 times 3 000 whatever that is that's
probably what it brings in i don't know
i want to have a million a month right
is that right i don't know sure i think
that sounds like yeah that's right yeah
yeah by zero or two rounding errors
that's not so yeah how did you get
started yeah man in real estate yeah so
you know i was bowling it all started
with bowling right so i was bowling and
i'm there with this
friend who's a real estate agent and i
said oh i'm actually looking for a place
to rent i'm 20 20 years old at times i'm
looking forward to rent she goes why are
you gonna rent just buy something i'm
like well because i'm 20 i have no
credit i have a job making eight dollars
an hour uh and like i don't i can't my
house have no money she's like
trust me it's 2007 right she's like
trust me we can get you alone call the
bank tell them the same thing i'm like i
got no nothing i mean nothing they're
like great you're approved
because that's what 2007 was so anyway i
i knew enough to buy
you know not go by the nicest property
in the world because i was making nine
dollars or whatever it was an hour yeah
i bought the dumpiest property i could
find i was just like a single family
house and i bought it for 80 grand and i
rented all the bedrooms and uh it worked
and that was at the peak of the market
2007 was like right before like the
bubble was about to pop and you're like
nope i'm gonna get in there right
beforehand but first we want to thank
our sponsor betterhelp is there
something that's interfering with your
happiness or stopping you from being the
best overall version of yourself well
betterhelp is here to help you become
that person betterhelp is not a crisis
line nor is it self-help it's
professional online therapy done
securely balancing your finances and
your overall mental wellness can be
difficult and you shouldn't have to pick
one or the other well betterhelp is here
to tell you that you don't have to make
that choice with betterhelp you can
start communicating with professionals
within 48 hours and it's available
worldwide and you can access your
account anytime to message your
therapist whenever you need with
traditional in-person therapy you have
to sit awkwardly and uncomfortably in a
waiting room but with better help you
get the safety and comfort of your own
home without sacrificing any of the
professionalism finding the right
therapist can be an absolute nightmare
but fortunately betterhelp is committed
to find you the right match for all of
your therapy needs therapy does not have
to break the bank and you shouldn't have
to choose financial security over
getting help and since better help is
more affordable than your traditional
offline therapy it's the perfect
solution start living a happier better
life today by visiting betterhelp.com
iced coffee hour that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people
taking charge of their mental health
with experienced professionals special
offer for all iced coffee hour listeners
you can get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com iced coffee hour thank
you so much better hope for sponsoring
this episode and back to the podcast so
it was and you know what's funny though
full circle this picture right so i
bought the house living it only for a
year uh not even that was like nine
months and i sold it uh and actually
bought it for 80 sold it's like 130 and
that was like the peak of the market and
it started crashing right that's a great
return
and then the market crashes the thing
was probably not even worth 90 to people
who bought it and it's like oh boohoo on
them right thing's worth 250 today and
they still own it so like that's one
thing i level real estate is you hold on
long enough you're probably going to be
fine as long as you can hold on so you
you bought it and then you held it for
what was it like nine months yeah but
what compelled you to sell it after only
holding it for nine years actually i was
like i'm gonna go i was like i want to
backpack europe that's what i was like
you were so lucky
i didn't it's not that's cool okay it's
it's not that cool but it's cool i was
like i'm gonna go backpack europe i just
had that thought one day just like i
want to go backpack europe so i
started asking a question how do i
backpack europe for a year how do i do
that and i thought well if i sold my
house i could probably do that i'd
probably get some money out of the house
so i sold the house uh instead i got
married so it's cool right i met my wife
and we got married and it's great and i
went to europe like two years later but
that's how it started i sold the house
and took the money and had a wedding
what were you doing when you were making
nine bucks an hour uh i was working
overnight at a group home so for like
developmentally disabled
thought i could sit there and watch like
music videos of like punk rock bands all
night that was like my entire job would
sit on the couch watch music videos and
tv
and make sure it was a heyday of mtv
yeah so good i was like follow up boys
like era and i was just like listening
to fall out boy videos all day long
all night did you go to college uh i did
i got a history degree okay it was like
one of those like i went to like five
different schools and kind of like at
the end i was like i got all these
credits can i get a degree and they
mailed me something and
i don't use it at all okay
so what was your like plan at that point
you said you graduated college yeah and
then and then from there you went to
work at the the home yeah and then did
you have any like long-term goals in
mind or were you just kind of taking
life as it comes you know i i was in
college i chose a history degree simply
because it was the fastest way out of
college i was like i talked to the
guidance counselor or whatever when i
when i went to the final school and i
was like well i got all these random
credits from random things what can i do
with it they're like well if you know
history you can get out a quarter
earlier like yes i will do that so i did
a history degree and then there's three
jobs you can do with a history degree
there's like you can be a teacher you
can be a lawyer or you can be homeless
so like i chose the his uh i chose the
history first the degree and then i
think i'm gonna go and uh be a lawyer uh
and then i read john grisham's book you
read the firm john grisham you ever seen
the movie yes okay the movie yeah it's
all about like this lawyer who's like
the mobs after him and all that which i
mean it's an entertaining story right
but what i got from that book was like
the idea that like these lawyers work
for like 40 years working 90 hours a
week and like they go through like four
wives and then at the end of their life
they just like hate themselves and like
there's like that's like the life of a
lawyer uh for a lot of like law people
and i was like wait what am i doing like
that sounds like i'm like yeah it makes
good money but what's the point of
making 200 000 a year if you're working
90 hours a week to get it right so like
that that book the firm made me change
my mind and decide instead well this
house thing is kind of cool what if i
bought another house and fixed it up and
then sold it so i thought i'm going to
go flip house instead of watching the
flipping shows and started flipping the
show i loved was flipping vegas yeah
yeah what was that uh scott yancey i
think was his name yeah that's not
anymore is it nope yeah those flipping
shows don't last too long but no they
don't yeah there's been a lot of them
that just come and go and they're all
the same but they're all they're good
for inspiration and just like they're
like oh i could do that that's cool and
i found out i couldn't do it i was
terrible at it and like trying to flip
houses in 08 just terrible so yeah so
what was your first flip attempt yeah
bought a house for 45 000 and it was
just a nasty old house built in like
1902 and
put maybe 50 grand into it like 95 into
it
and then tried to sell for 130 and then
the market's just crashing i mean i
could have made 25 30 grand after fees
but the market was just crappy and
couldn't sell it so i ended up
refinancing it so for those who don't
know it's like you know go to the bank
get a brand new loan
and so i got a brand new loan on it that
was like a 30-year mortgage so i didn't
have to worry about paying it off
anytime soon
and then it like just rented it out to
some dude he was like a contractor and
all of a sudden i was making more money
on rent than what my mortgage and all
expenses was uh so i was making cash
flow and like it was actually super i
mean relatively super easy
and i was like this rental thing is kind
of cool so that's how it kind of started
the idea into rentals what was your job
though at the time because you had to
have an income i didn't have the job
actually so this is now i mean i had the
job i quit the job to flip that house
right so i had no job while i was
slopping the house and then i
couldn't refinance can't refinance
without a job right so actually to
refinance it i wouldn't ask my dad i was
like i was like i'm like 22 at the time
i'm like hey can i just add you on to
the mortgage and just so your name's
attached to it and then we go to the
bank and now it's your name on it he's
like i don't care and i was like i'll
give you you know someday i think i said
like someday i'll give you half the
profit when i sell the property whenever
we do he's like ah okay that's fine and
so yeah we added them on to the property
and then i went and refinanced it and
that idea of like the adding the
partners on i mean i've done that now on
almost every deal i've ever done i've
done with partners because like the big
thing with real estate is everyone's
like well i don't have enough money i
can't afford to do it i can't you know
there's tons of people out there who
have
money and they just don't have the time
or the i mean they're not sitting here
watching a youtube video or listening to
a podcast
they are maybe they are they probably
are
know there's people with money and then
there's people who have hustle yeah and
if you can put that together i mean it's
it's sometimes people have both right
but it's rare most people either they
have a job they're working at the county
they're working out the state whatever
they're making good money they're a
lawyer working 200 000 you know
hours a year
but uh yeah so now i do partnerships for
almost everything
and what year was this the the flip
attempt yeah that would have been 08 i
think the first flip was a weight
and i decided that flipping yeah
flipping wasn't really for me i tried a
few more times never really made any
money lost a little bit of money
sometimes but the rental thing just kept
working like you just every rental you
buy i once heard this analogy every
rental is like a little oil well right
little oil well you can text that's
right you drive through this oil pump
and oil out of the ground every rental
you buy is an oil well so you have one
and you're making 100 bucks a month it's
like well that's not very much then you
buy a duplex and now you're making you
know two or three hundred a month then
you buy another little duplex and then
you're making 500 a month and just each
one is just pumping oil out of the
ground every day every month every year
and it adds up so by the time i was 27 i
had like 3 500 bucks a month in cash
flow and i was like i am the richest
person i know so i quote my i got
another job at the time just to pay some
bills quit that job and sat on the couch
and retired when i was 27. did you yeah
i mean i literally sat on the couch and
watched tv for like three or four months
did you like that no it was terrible it
was why what was bad about that yeah i
mean daytime tv is terrible right
[Laughter]
there's just like
i i think like i don't know if it's like
i i don't know i i'm so much of my life
is wrapped up in like my identity of
like being a hard worker so then all of
a sudden you just sit down and do
nothing
there just wasn't fulfilling whatsoever
i think i have this theory that anybody
who's able to retire early in life can't
retire early in life uh it's like if
you're able if you're smart enough and
you are good enough and you work hard
enough to retire at a young age you just
never take it and like they have stats
that show when people even older people
when they retire you can you can predict
someone's age of death by when they
retire you're you know you retire at
whatever 65 you'll die at like 75. but
you retire at 75 and die 85. this is
something that like humans are built to
work and built to keep the mind going
oh my gosh all right well that's it
sorry bailey so i want to know the exact
events that happened in the timeline to
get to like being 27 making 3 500 a
month because i'm kind of in the
beginning of that journey where i got my
first property and i want to start
leveling up and getting more properties
and making more like you know income
doing this but it seems like it seems
very difficult to like get to where you
were at 27. how did you do that exactly
yeah all right let's talk about house
hacking so yeah all right so i'll
backtrack a little bit back in when i
did that very first flip right i sold
the first house uh where i made a little
bit of money and got married right then
i needed a place to live because i'm
broke so i flip at the same time i
bought that house to flip the first one
that was a failure
and then i bought a duplex i didn't know
anything about duplexes i didn't know
anything really even at the time about
rentals i just bought it was a duplex
for sale for 80 000
it was two houses on one lot so they
weren't even connected there's a little
yard in between
one of them was a one bedroom one bath
400 square foot house that's what i
lived in they call them like casitas in
some areas they call them ohana's out in
hawaii they call them mother-in-law
apartments whatever so i'm gonna sell a
one-bedroom one-bath house
literally like six inches from the
alleyway where like just people are like
going through on bicycles and doing
drugs and stuff and then the front house
was a two bedroom one bath again a
little tiny house but i remember the day
i mean it vividly in my imaginary not
measuring vividly in my head i remember
the tenant in the front unit the first
day bringing me rent and he brings me
cash like 650 bucks and it totally looks
like a drug deal because we're like in
the driveway between these two houses
and next to an alleyway and it gives me
the 650
and i'm like holding this and i remember
just like thinking wait a second my
mortgage is 620
and this is 650 i'm living for free i'm
getting paid to live for free i'm making
30 bucks a month again i'm like super
rich right i'm at the time you know
again i'm like 21 at this point 22
somewhere in there and uh
like that was just like this light bulb
moment and i remember thinking also if i
had a lot of them
like then that would be cash flow it's
kind of how i started discovering cash
flow i started then somebody recommended
it oh if you're into this go read rich
dad poor dad so i read rich dad poor dad
i'm like yes like it's like that book
put
words to like this like groaning in my
soul right it was like i know there's
something out there that's not
that's not
the work 90 hours a week for 40 years
just to retire the you know and be the
richest dead guy right like there's more
to life than that and rich dad poor dad
was like this is here's some words to
put to that why you feel that way so
rich dad poor dad started there then i
went to the library and i read 100 books
over a summer like probably over 100 but
i remember i stopped counting around
100.
100 books on real estate just everything
i could find on it and it really just
came down to at the time of every house
this was literally my thought at the
time if every property i buy
i could make a hundred dollars in profit
and i need roughly three grand to pay my
bills
i just need to collect units i just need
to collect them so i don't care how i
get them so it started with house
hacking so i bought the duplex lived in
one unit then i went and moved into
another duplex and lived in one of the
units rented the other one out and the
great thing about house hacking is the
government
subsidizes a loan called fha you've
probably talked about the show before
but like fha loans are three and a half
percent down so if you're gonna buy a
hundred thousand dollar property you're
paying 3 500 bucks and that can be
gifted from like a family member so you
could literally like you know get into a
property for really nothing if you're a
military person you get in for zero down
same thing
uh so if and again some people are like
well hundred thousand dollars you can't
do that okay fine three hundred thousand
dollars you're in for 12 grand like it's
not a ridiculous amount of money to be
able to do that and if you're buying the
in the fha loan works for duplex or
single family duplex triplex fourplex
so one of the best strategies in the
world i tell new investors all the time
is go buy the fourplex if you can't if
you can find it or triplex but if you
can live in one of the units you have to
say you're gonna live it for a year you
have to intend to live there for a year
you live in one unit you can rent the
other ones out what that does is if you
can live for free or even just cheaper
right if you can live for cheaper or buy
a house with bedrooms right rent the
bedrooms out especially if you're young
dang like if you can get rid of that
burden of
your housing payment which is the
biggest expense anyone has
all of a sudden you have like
flexibility and all of a sudden you can
set aside money to invest or to build a
business or you can take a big risk and
be like well i'm not paying anything to
live anyway i'm living cheap so i'm
gonna go and you know go take a job at
this startup which is probably gonna
fail but if it does do well i'll make
millions and so you can take those risks
in life which you can't do when you're
just strapped with debt and mortgages
and everything yeah people will spend
what's crazy people will spend
so much time and effort worried about
how to like save four bucks on a latte
right and there's something about
frugality i'm a big fan right i know you
talk a lot about that right
but how often are people thinking how do
i save a thousand or two thousand
dollars a month on where i live oh if i
just have like a duplex i can drop my
mortgage i can save a thousand or
fifteen hundred dollars a month
just by having a tenant and yeah is that
easy not always but it's not that hard
either like it's just like a stuff you
learn so anyway house hacking is how
really i built up the first like four or
five properties was just move in rent it
out move rent it out move rent it out
and uh from there you get into
multi-family and then it gets fun yeah i
loved my duplex i have to say i loved it
that was so much fun
and uh i got so into basically tracking
just what the mortgage would be and i'd
add in the tax write-offs and then i'd
count the equity back and be like
technically now with this and then i'm
paying down this mortgage but like 800 i
think it was like 800 or 900 a month of
that was uh equity and i'm like every
day that's 30
yep 30 bucks a day that's over a dollar
an hour so i'd be like i'll wake up and
i'll be like well i just
got another eight bucks yep yeah i loved
it i loved it such a great way to get
and it's like it's like real estate
investing with training wheels right
because like it's not like super risky
you're not putting that much money into
it you got a long-term mortgage that
really like it's it's fixed it's not
going anywhere it's staying the same
right and if something goes wrong i mean
you're there like so i remember like
yeah like maybe three times a year i get
a phone call about some problem and i'd
have to go fix some leak i could have
called up you know contractor but i just
like to tinker and try to fix things
myself so i'd get like the book from
home depot it's called like one two
three home improvement like here's how
you fix the plumbing leak and i'd figure
it out just because it was fun but yeah
that stuff man like it's just character
building but also skill building and
that i still you know man it's it's
still what i love today like i still i
mean i house hack right now i live in
hawaii i have like a two ish million
dollar house and like i have an extra
unit in the back i rent out yeah uh and
then i have a basement i could rent out
if i wanted to i just keep it for
friends and family but
i get at any point rent it out and then
live for free in a two million dollar
house overlooking the ocean in hawaii
like this works at any level like it i
can vouch for that i saw this place it
is is it nice nice oh man you drive up
the driveway and the house is up at the
top and then he's got the pool and then
this entire like your office the
seashell yeah the shed yeah and then a
property in the back and a huge backyard
where they grow up oh it's gone like
vegetables the backyard's gone why yeah
we hit by a flash flood last week i
haven't seen it yet but you see that
flash flood came through it's crazy like
it took the whole backyard out no the
garden the tables everything i mean it's
gone um you know it's funny you were
just telling me it never rains
it rained 17 inches i think it was in
like a night no it rains three inches a
year and i'm in the desert like
basically like a classified desert and
uh they got this freak storm it took my
whole yeah my wife was at home with the
kids yeah she's calling me i'm at like
this honky tonk bar in like nashville
with a bunch of friends having a great
time that's why i lost my voice right
and she called me she's like the house
is gonna collapse and like she's like
freaked out yeah and uh yeah it was
messed up so anyway i get to go back
home here in a few days and apparently i
have no backyard so but insurance would
actually not
because no flood insurance no flood
insurance i mean why would i get flinch
i'm on a hill
and i like i'm on a hill in the desert
like there's no reason for me i would
ever thought to get flood insurance now
that said i mean
what's what's 10 15 20 grand to fix it
up it's not into the world like more
than that
i mean like excavation of all the mud
and stuff like that yeah but i got see i
got some contractors that like live out
there that work for me so like they just
like for the first i mean they've been
out there for a week every day now so i
mean i'll probably be in for 15 20 grand
and it's like okay well
it's not the end of the world right yeah
it's not terrible and this is you know
things like that scare people when i
talk about this people are like oh
that's why i don't want to get into real
estate right like i'm like it's just
it's like what's that quote if you have
a problem that can be solved by money
and you have money you don't have a
problem and so it's easy to get
overwhelmed by that stuff and be like oh
man it's uh you're like no just write a
check like it's not a big deal speaking
of that i'll take a screenshot of this
this is a repair so i've gone a little
while without a repair and this came up
i'll show you a picture of this
so this was uh
part well not partly my fault i was an
idiot
is that the main line uh yep hey
mainline brothers oh yeah
so you're right so you're looking at uh
i think it was 7 800
yeah
so let me tell you this this was my
mistake i had an issue a year ago
and uh they basically said
for two grand
we can make this work
it'll fix it it's not going to be a
permanent solution but this could last
you a year it can last you 10 years it's
just it's it's a pipe from the 1950s so
they're like you know we're going to do
a quick and it i think they quoted me at
the time like ten thousand to fix it the
right way so i figured
i'm just gonna pay the two grand and
problem solved yeah
exactly a year later when he was telling
me it could last year but a year later
yeah and then uh they ended up refixing
what i fixed a year ago because they're
like it's easier for us to do the entire
thing all at once than keep their work
yep explain what happened so you didn't
say oh yeah so what happened was
basically uh the pipe was really old it
was i think it was a ceramic or
something from there from the 1950s uh
over time roots got into it so they've
been hydro jetting it but uh i didn't
hydrogen for a little while and it
cracked the pipe and then over time the
pipe kind of shifted yeah and uh water
basically started backing up
so that sounds fun but like it's one of
those things right you if you have a
problem and you have money they can
solve it you don't have a problem uh it
sucks especially when you have a rental
that like you rely on it to bring
bringing money but here's the thing this
is probably like the
if i get like one tip for anybody who
wants to get into real estate it's this
like know that that stuff does happen
and it happens all the time it's not
like a shock it's not like oh my gosh i
can't believe that you know of course
everything breaks down the so if you
account for it like
then you're fine i mean for example like
what i mean by that is like let's say
you buy a property and you're like this
thing is gonna rent out for a thousand
dollars a month my mortgage is gonna be
800 a month wow i'm making 200 a month
in profit no you're not like i would set
aside at least 100 if not 200 every
single month for that
because it only happens once every
couple years but it does happen and then
you know like two three years from now
you're gonna have another you have a
roof leak and that's gonna be three
grand to fix it your water heater is
gonna go out in five years and it's
putting one of those in it happens all
the time we call that capex uh it's it's
it is a real number it just it doesn't
happen monthly and so people forget
about it and so they buy property
thinking it's going to make them money
and then in reality it just loses the
money now thankfully we say real estate
is a forgiving asset class my buddy
david who's on the podcast the bigger
pockets podcast with me he calls he says
cash flow is a defensive metric it's not
designed cash flow's not designed to
make you rich it's designed to help you
hold on long enough
like riding a bronco you know or a bull
you know if you're in a row you got to
hold on like it's like duct taping your
legs to the bowl right like you're not
going to fall off if you have cash flow
because you can handle things like that
but what you really want is to hang on
long enough that 10 years later that
property's gone up in value because yeah
real estate goes up and down but it goes
up and down an upward trend and so like
i said that house that i sold at 130
dropped till under 100. now it's worth
two something like it's just it's the
way real estate tends to work especially
when the government's printing as much
money as there so if you can hang on
long enough real estate is phenomenal uh
and then the cash flow is good in the
meantime too i don't think we ever
mentioned where exactly you were buying
initially yeah oh actually yeah that so
this actually plays into my story a
little bit this is cool so
that very first duplex right i lived in
the alleyway right that little crappy
house and had the had the tenant there
uh this is in aberdeen washington so
aberdeen washington technically hoke
washington but grays harbor county
washington which uh
is famous only for one thing so grace
harbor is famous because that's where
nirvana came out of i remember kurt
cobain nirvana that whole thing came out
of aberdeen uh so anyway so my house
there this little crappy duplex uh after
about a year of owning it uh the tenants
were like hey people keep taking
pictures of our house and i was like
what do you mean taking pictures of the
house yeah we just keep seeing flashes
through our windows and i was like nah
the county must be reappraising or
something right and then it went several
years the tenant would be like yeah more
people taking pictures couldn't figure
it out for a while
finally we learned what it was when some
swedish tourists knocked on the door and
they wanted a tour of the cobain house
no and we're like the cobain house and
we find out and i look it up online i
find out it was the house he was born in
like on his birth certificate like not
literally on the floor but like that's
his parents where his parents were in
both houses they lived in this little
shack in the back where i lived when he
was born and then at six months old they
moved into the front house and they
lived in that i'm the only person who
owns two of kurt cobain's former houses
he's still on it i actually just sold
that a few months no no no no no i know
because obviously if you can afford to
hold on to that i know that's a piece of
history i know it was cool and i loved
it i had it for 15 years it was cool
but the bragging rights like the cool
story that it's fun to tell right it's a
cool story
it wasn't worth just the mental headache
of hanging on to that problem what's the
headache it was in a crappy neighborhood
like it was an alleyway i mean it's so
like it just attracted like rough
tenants like i always like to say like
bad like rough houses attract rough
tenants and and so like i like nasty
properties attract nasty people it just
is what it is they know dude do things
know this is kurt cobain's house we tell
the tenant after they move in but i
don't i don't want to advertise it
because i don't want the kind of person
who would rent like would rent a house
because it's kurt cobain
i don't know seriously if you may be
able to charge higher rent yeah you'll
be able to charge higher rates
and you would attract a better tenant
who could here's the thing i think it
was a marketing problem because you're
marketing this normal house i agree and
that would attract those sort of tenants
you market this as kurt cobain's house
you're in uh what was it realist.com you
get in all the magazines and online i
did think of that because they were
selling one of his other houses yeah a
million bucks but so so here's the thing
it's like you're going to attract tenant
who's okay with the the less desirable
area even though they're a higher
caliber tenant because it's kurt
cobain's house and they they get the
bragging right it was a crappy house
though it doesn't matter dumpy house it
doesn't matter i feel like that it's
hard to replace that kirkovan's house in
hollywood is very similar to that and
it's run down i think it's like empty
and you get these youtube people who
like sneak into the house
film it but uh
stuff like that like you get a bit of a
premium yeah we thought about turning
into airbnb and we kicked it around for
a while but i didn't want the headache
of it and then i thought about you know
selling it as like you know like it was
like baby house right so it's not like
there's another house in town where he's
like his writing is all over the walls
like that house is like people are like
that's the cobain house i just have the
baby house so i kept it and then finally
i was like here's here's actually why i
sold it i do what's called a return on
equity calculation right so you look how
much equity on your property how much
you'd actually make if you sold it
and then you say well how much cash flow
did i make last year compared to how
much i would have if i sold it and my
return on equity was like 1.3 percent
i'm like well shoot i'm making no money
on this thing i might as well just go
and stick in the stock market and make
more than one percent so it was it was a
financial thing but i'm actually selling
almost everything i own in that town
like what what got me to financial
freedom is those first deals which is
great i don't regret any of that but
that's
now though that's a hindrance to me
becoming like the next level of whatever
that is right i couldn't i don't think i
could have bought the 3000 units without
getting rid of the 30 that i started
with it's just a mental
drain on like
you know the 3000 units actually take
more or take less effort to manage than
the 30. by far i mean because i have a
team and i have people there's like
there's systems for the 3000 but the 30
they're mine or mine with a partner and
that was just it was a headache so let
it go so you're liquidating all of your
own personal yeah all the ones that i i
own alone i want to get rid of pretty
much all of them i mean some of them
just like they still print money like an
atm machine and i like i like them but
it's it's just about like freeing up as
much as i can like mental energy to not
have to think about that stuff to move
it on so yeah getting rid of a lot of
the early stuff crazy wow yeah sorry
coco cricket bands is gone so how did
you scale from being 3 500 bucks a month
into now i don't even know a million and
a half in revenue and also at what point
did you get into bigger pockets with
that place yeah so that yeah so remember
i said the internet marketing thing
right so i sat on the couch started
getting internet marketing really liked
the idea like making videos like you go
back and watch my very first video
i'm not this animated i'm like sitting
in a chair like holding on where can we
find those videos yeah
it's on early bigger pockets really yeah
it's terrible oh here we go webinar the
advanced guide to analyzing it all right
yeah i remember that you look so
different yeah i had i think i had
glasses and no beard maybe
yeah oh wow look at the intro oh so good
look at that home for real estate
investing online but my first webinar i
ever did i've now done probably 500
webinars but that was the very first so
what was this webinar for
i just i think i was just like i'm gonna
do a webinar so josh dawkin by the way
started bigger pockets this is it
started his basement it was a little
hobby kind of blog for him
and uh i started like he he grew it it
was like bigger when it was a blog
around the blog
right so people would ask questions
in this q a forum and i actually found
bigger pockets i remember what i
searched i searched youtube for what to
do when tenants don't pay rent because i
had a family member who was like don't
do real estate man don't do real estate
it's terrible like you know uncle
whatever lost his shirt right everyone's
got a story of an uncle who lost his
shirt and really always the uncle he's
always the uncle and there's a lot of
uncle shirts missing somewhere
and so uh and they're like well your
tenant's not gonna pay rent and you know
you're gonna end up like having to cover
it yourself and you won't be able to
you're gonna lose all your money and be
homeless and live under a bridge
yourself it was like this like a real
estate horrible kind of
speech right so i went to google and i
was like what to do when tenants don't
pay rent and i find this cycle bigger
pockets i remember printing out the
article not that the like the answer was
fine i'm sure it was a good answer i
don't remember what the answer said but
what it told me
was there was answers to all those like
naysayers right just like when people
were like yo you shouldn't invest in
crypto or you shouldn't invest in the
stock market it's risky you shouldn't be
an entrepreneur shouldn't start a
business everyone's got like this reason
why you shouldn't but when you get
around people who are actually doing it
it's like it's it's so freeing you're
like oh like
i can actually do it because other
people are doing it right like nobody
knows like if you don't know real estate
like why would you listen to those
people about whether you can do it or
not
so i found bigger pockets i started uh
helping out just well asking questions
in the forums like people can go back to
my early posts and be like i'm like how
do i buy a duplex you know i'm asking
all these questions
and that led to uh
me meaning josh dorkan so again at the
time it was just kind of a hobby for him
then he kind of made it a business but
it was still pretty small at the time
and i started editing blog posts for him
he's just like hey i'm looking for some
help can you edit i'm like i can edit it
was a lie i couldn't edit i don't know
how to i don't really i didn't know the
difference between like there there and
there right i just like pretend i'm like
oh yeah i'm really good at english why
did you want to join so bad did he have
a lot of credentials uh no but at the
time i had another blog it was called
real estate your 20s this is my entry
into uh investing uh i mean uh and my
entry into internet marketing so i had
real estate your 20s.com still there
right now i just haven't updated it a
decade but the idea was like i'm a big
believer that when it comes to internet
marketing or any marketing really but i
want to be the intersection of two
points right so it was real estate for
young people in your 20s and it actually
worked pretty well it started growing
and started doing better but the way
back in the day maybe it still works
this way but
the way that it really worked was you'd
go and guest post on somebody else's
blog who is bigger i guess on youtube
you go and you know jv with somebody on
a youtube channel right so i was guest
blogging for josh as a way to grow mine
and then when he was looking for help
like i mean i'm making three grand a
month like it wasn't that much money at
the time and i'm like well he's going to
pay me to do this and i think it was i
think he paid me like a hundred bucks a
post to like edit it and then post it on
the blog so i was making some money at
that point i was just like a 1099
contractor and uh
we just found out we liked each other we
like started talking every day and like
the few hours of editing blog posts
turned into like nine hours of working
straight through and just chatting on on
skype at the time and then that led to
hey maybe we should start a podcast
and that's when the biggerpockets
podcast started as we we started a
podcast i remember i was thinking like i
want to be like top 100 business podcast
within five years that was like our goal
we wrote down it was like the first week
we were like number five and like never
dropped below number 20 in the last nine
years how did you scale so quickly uh i
mean we had an email list so by that
point josh had an email list i remember
he hit a hundred thousand people on his
email list that's good yeah that was
good yeah what year was that that would
have been oh shoot 2011.
not bad yeah 2011 2012. yeah so i mean
he has spent a decade building that list
a lot of people like falsely think that
i started bigger pockets no i came in
like a decade after josh the reason that
bigger pockets is successful is not
because i came in even though that's
when it hockey sticked up but that
wasn't because of me it was because
josh did 10 years of making no money
there's such a lesson in this right like
almost everybody i know who is really
successful in business
there was years of not making any money
before it hockey sticked up every once
in a while you see somebody who's just
like oh yeah right off the bat they did
it right but most of the time there's
years of you what you don't see
and majority people give up somewhere in
that right they get excited about their
business and then it's like oh the
reality sets in and then they give up
but josh stuck with it for years and
years and years until he finally had
enough money to be able to hire his very
first person which was me
and so then i came in to help edit blog
posts in the
podcast and then it just grew from there
so now the email list and i don't know
why the podcast took off and we were
early obviously like i mean at the time
it's funny at the time i thought we were
so late i was like everybody's got a
podcast it's 2011. like everybody has a
podcast
and like they're good look at these
podcasts and so i never like is crazy
yeah and then it just became the biggest
real estate podcast right away and never
really left that and so it became the
just a big show so yeah crazy 550
episodes later so why leave yeah and we
should go into that before we go into
more real estate we're on the topic yeah
uh so i love i still love bigger pockets
i love it very much and still i'm still
part owner of the company uh i will
maintain that and i'll still be around
like we're still together but i just
have this like
one i live in hawaii now i got two
little kids two and five
and
just like selling my old rental
properties i needed to clear that mental
bandwidth out of my life
bigger pockets i needed to break from
the like like now it's a monotony
because it's really actually enjoyable
the podcast and youtube
but i needed a break from that so i can
refocus on family and on you know the
real estate company that i built um odc
uh and so like
we
decided my wife and i were like i think
this is time to just step back let the
company do what it does because here's a
problem right when you have a company
that is
heavily dependent upon one person now i
mean there's 50 people that work at
bigger pockets and they're all amazing
but when people think bigger pockets
they think of me like a lot of people do
right how do you sell a business someday
or how do you how do you
go public i mean i don't know where
bigger pockets gonna sell or go public
again like it sold a few years ago
partially but like
how do you eventually liquidate a
company when it's dependent on one
person you can't it's really really
really hard and so we all knew this was
a band-aid that we had to rip off at
some point that we had to get out of me
being the
center and so it was kind of a
might as well do it now before like you
know have to do eventually oh it's so
tough because for a while i believed
that you were bigger pockets yeah see a
lot of people everyone is like oh
brandon from bigger pockets it's just
like it's flowed so nicely and as you as
the face of that was like hey some guy's
really into real estate house hacking
who gets down to the nitty-gritty it's
like it's a good story it's a good image
and it's like everyone can relate to
that yeah yeah and it was it's a it was
great and i'm not saying i'm gone
forever i like the idea of thinking like
so here's what it was this is an
interesting thing so i have a
performance coach his name's jason dries
he's awesome and he asked yes as a good
performance coach does they ask good
questions
and then it's almost like therapy it's
it's it's like
he we're talking about me being just
stressed out and i feel like i'm working
too many hours and like i don't work
that many hours but when like many hours
is too many hours when i've got little
kids that i'd rather be with
and so he said
have you ever thought about taking a
sabbatical just like
take a month off and i was like oh
that's a really good question because i
do that
do i need a sabbatical and as soon as i
said yeah i'm going to take a month i
mean i went
nine years without missing an episode i
think i had one episode somewhere in the
middle where i missed but i went nine
years it was me every single week i'm
the continuity
and all of a sudden i was like huh
i could take a month off i can i can
detach my identity from the podcast for
a little bit
and as soon as i did that i tore
something like it like tore
the the connection between me and i have
to be the guy in the podcast i have to
be the one doing it i have to be the one
running every piece of my company and
once i tore that a little bit it was no
longer attached i was like oh well if
i'm gonna take a month off what if i
took three months off and then like five
minutes later i'm like what if i took
six months off and then i was like what
if i take indefinitely off and it was
doable i could not go from brandon on
the podcast to leaving the podcast but i
had to once i just tore that a little
bit it opened up the rest which is just
a weird like psychological thing that i
think a lot of people go through their
identity is in their job or in their
career in that whatever that is and they
just it's so hard to leave that so
finally came time and
yeah
they'll do fine
if people love the the brand bigger
pockets are so strong now that they'll
do all right yeah how do the episodes do
when you're not in them
uh some of them do really well uh what
people like uh
is the data a lot we found that people
like data a lot so we've got you know
david green everyone loves david green
he's my co-host and he's really good at
metaphors he's one of the smartest
people i've ever met and they love david
but they also we have we have a new show
now we're on the same channel where
they're going through data like here's
all this crazy information about the
real estate market and here's what it
means and people love those shows i'm
not that guy like i can't tell you what
the you know per capita income is of
cleveland i don't care like that's not
how that's not my job i can hype you up
and i get you really excited about real
estate and i can explain why it's good
and 100 a month and you know little oil
wells i love that stuff but i'm not a
data guy so
it's good they'll uh they'll experiment
but you know you ever watch
what's the show called kelly and live
with kelly and rachel oh it used to be
so it was regis and kathy lee right yeah
originally so this is probably before
like when i was in like high school
then kathy lee left and it was regis and
kelly yeah then regis left and it was
kelly and michael then michael left and
was kelly and ryan
so i liked michael yeah michael was cool
right yeah yeah straight stathan
strathan them
yeah
yeah yeah yeah i loved you yeah he was
so funny this is a talk show or
something yeah
morning like morning like today show
kind of thing oh okay jack's too young
to remember yes exactly yeah this was
so today's ryan seacrest and so every
time that happens in that show people
are like this show sucks like ever
because like you get used to the people
like imagine if something like you left
the show right people were like like
this guy's right like
or if you left people would be like hey
we miss them bring them back right
but they get over it and people will get
over it and there's gonna be a dip
probably and they'll be like well we
want brandon back because that's what
they're used to
and then they'll get somebody else in
there and then they'll get used to that
person and i'll pop back and be like hey
i'm still alive yeah that'll be fun so
yeah it's crazy interesting yeah so what
are you working on over the next year
oh man i don't know uh
i really want to get better at surfing
yeah it's a big piece of it uh i want to
write another book or two i've written a
bunch and i like writing a lot so i'll
probably write a book or two maybe if i
get bored but man i just want to like i
want to watch my kids grow up you know
you don't get that again right i mean
you guys don't have kids yet right but i
always just have another kid though i
could have another kid i want more kids
kids are so much fun there's a horrible
amount of work but it's so rewarding and
so i'd love to have another kid so i can
practice that throughout the year it'll
be great
get it
thanks joe but uh
oh anyway so uh
yeah please this show just went pg-13
so that's all yeah i i don't really know
but i want that
i think it's just really good for people
to have
more mar what they call a margin in your
life uh whether it's in your day like
when i wake up in the morning the days
that i start with like a buffer like
that margin uh just my days go better
yeah what do you mean margin like um
space between when you wake up and when
you get to work right or even like
in your day like taking five minute
breaks like having margin like edges
around your day or in the middle of your
day that just breaks things up so you're
not just like thinking the thing the
thing to think but taking time to just
like
like relax and like think in fact i do a
thing every single week i have this like
amazing massage therapist lady from the
four seasons hotel comes to my house i'm
elena you stood on that front porch
right and she gives me a 90 minute
massage and my wife gets like a 90
minute massage every week it's crazy
expensive right to do the same time
one at a time right so i think it's a
couple hundred bucks a week maybe each
person right a couple hundred away each
person yeah i think i think it's a
hundred and fifty i don't know these
numbers i think it's like 150 bucks and
for an hour and a half that's way way
but and she comes to you yeah it comes
to me that's cheap yeah i mean it's not
bad for a massage correct to come to you
for an hour and a half yeah it's not bad
it's not terrible right yeah but you do
it now it's but you made my wife both
now it's 300 a week times four it's 1200
bucks a month let's call it some people
would say that's a frivolous waste of
money that is the most profitable hour
and a half of my week by far when i'm on
that massage table because that's buffer
that's margin in my life
where
the first at the first hour of that
right there's a this is important 90
minutes is more to me anyway
90 minutes matters 60 minutes doesn't do
just like a 60 minute run doesn't do it
for me a 90 minute run changes my life
and here's why the first hour of that
like boredom no phone no nothing
your brain's like bored first of all
it's trying to like find ways to get the
dopamine hit that you get every time you
swipe right and for the first hour it's
like just all over just scrambled you're
thinking of a hundred different things
but then at some point in there your
brain starts to think of something
that's important you get through the
clutter and it starts to focus on a
thing
some problem in your life or some
situation or some business idea and so i
liken it to a tornado right so a tornado
like it's whirling around like this
really fast and then it starts to like
cycle it on something and then you get
just on some topic in your head in the
last 30 minutes that massage is where
like i would say 9 out of 10 of my best
ideas for whether it's video content or
uh i mean business ideas problems that
i'm going with in business how to go
like open door capital like you know the
company i founded like so much of that
has
been because of that that margin that
time
so
going back
the year that i'm that i'm taking off is
really designed to be a year of just
margin uh people call them sabbaticals
so like that's what it's about just
taking that time in fact i have that
margin every week friday night at sunset
like we shut off our phones no phone no
tv unless it's like a family movie
uh which is like a you know a cool thing
to do right but like it's margin there's
no phone there's no work there's no
shopping we don't go shopping we don't
spend money other than maybe go to
coffee together
and it it forces you to slow down and
just add that margin in your week so i'm
all about like margin of my day margin
my week and now margin in my life and so
when you add that in there it just adds
a richness and a depth to your life that
i think i lacked for a long time and the
more i lean into that uh the more happy
and fulfilled i am getting i want a
massage now let's do right now come on
uh
you used to get them man yeah i did so i
was about to say so uh in l.a at the
oppenheim group right below there was
this massage place that had happy hour
of massage get this 35 dollars for an
hour
and it was the best massage it's great
because i've tried a few since then in
other places and i've yet to find one
i'm really happy with and some of them
they hurt like i went to one it was a
good deal i think it was like and here
they're expensive i think it was like 80
bucks yeah they're expensive yes it was
like eighty dollars for an hour which is
normal the other place was really cheap
35 is really cheap yeah but the entire
thing was a painful experience and like
she found a knot and yeah yeah sometimes
it hurts
and it was like this isn't relaxing to
me this doesn't help me now i'm just
like i'm trying to like breathe through
the pain but the the one in la
was so relaxing and it got to a point
where i i would usually do one about
once every week and a half or so but i'd
come up with some of the video ideas
yeah because it's just like you you
don't think of anything and just ideas
come through and i'm like oh that's a
good idea and entirely i'm sometimes
like oh i should write that down but i
don't yeah but i come out of him like
three ideas i started leaving a notebook
so you know how you have the massage
table it has like the the circle you put
your face in it so you're looking down
at the ground usually i started
literally putting a notebook and a pen
underneath that and the massage lady
just knows she knows that like in the
middle of that i'll just stop like hold
on and i can reach it because my arms
are like ridiculously long they call me
the human selfie stick
so like i will reach down and i'll just
write the idea down so i don't forget it
uh you can also take your phone just
like do a voice memo like underneath
you know the massage person's gonna
think you're crazy but it's uh yeah it's
so powerful adding that breaks in your
life that's why people like meditation
i'm not a huge meditation guy right but
it's the same concept just taking time
to slow down it's it's huge i'm doing
that every day now meditation
plan okay yeah that's cool it's pretty
good good ah
i'm i'm pretty like uh wiry yeah yeah
like it's difficult for me to like sit
down and chill for a second like i'm
always like i just want to like give if
i'm ready to work if i want to meditate
that means i'm like good enough to work
yeah like for example i was meditating
last night but i'm like i just want to
set up my ikea occurrences right now
yeah you know
yeah i i did the meditation thing for a
few months and uh it helped but then i
missed a few days
it's like oh everything's fine i just
stopped yeah but uh
and now i'm so but i don't know yeah i
think it helped but i don't i didn't do
it long enough to really see it through
like i was not as consistent after a few
months yeah i think it's one of those
things that like you do for years and
you look back and you're like oh i can
see a big difference in my life
because of that yeah i don't do it
regularly i'm not i'm not graded i try
to and i feel like there's benefit there
but i just i don't do it what other
routines or life hacks do you do besides
like massages and and these like what
would be unique that that other people
could do yeah um
i'm a pretty big like goal planning kind
of guy uh like journaling like uh so
almost every morning i tried this i i
write down like my top three goals every
morning like these are the three things
i'm going for so once a court well let
me back up i've got a very clear vision
on where i'm headed with my company with
my life all that uh there's a great book
called vivid vision by a guy named
cameron harold it's all about like
having a very clear picture of where
your head not like a mission statement
not like a number but like
this is a
3 000 word article like this is what i
wrote or a 3000 word article about my
company like written it three years in
the future it was like this is what we
do that's what we are this is what our
team looks like this is what the media
thinks about us is as if it was like an
article in the new york times right so i
start with this vision i work to like
every year annual goal so actually just
that's why i'm here in town right now
we're doing our annual goal setting
tomorrow with my company so we're gonna
figure out the whole next year then i do
like quarterlys where i'm like this is
what i'm doing this quarter i take that
to my journal and i'm like what are the
three goals i'm working on this quarter
and what are the habits i track my
habits pretty meticulously so things
like i call them lead habits right
there's certain habits that if you do
they benefit a lot of areas of life for
example if i go to bed by like 10
o'clock at night i know that the next
morning it's way more likely i'm gonna
work out it's way more likely to be
really rested and feel really good it's
way more likely i'm going to then like
make a good video and actually want to
go do a podcast so there's like that one
thing of going to bed by 10 o'clock
affects so many other areas of my life
i'll be better for my kids and not so i
track things like that every single
morning i write down my goals every
morning i write down what i call your
mins mins it's like your most important
next step i mean think about this way
uh if if everything like if you had your
goal you know where you wanted and you
know what you're gonna get for the
quarter and you know what you want to do
uh you know this week even like i've
defined this week i want to do this most
people that's as far as they ever take
it they're like i want to go to the gym
this week
but or i want to make i'm going to make
a youtube video let's do that one right
i'm going to make a youtube video this
week
and then the week goes by and they never
made the youtube video and and really
when you break it down almost everything
in life is a series of five minute or
less tasks almost everything
so
i started asking myself the question
like what is the m-i-n-s most important
next step like the smallest tangible
thing and it literally might be like
open up my evernote and look at my list
of video ideas like that's it it's a
three second task and then so i have the
goal i have the week i have my most
important next step open up evernote and
then ask myself again like right after
that okay what's my means m-i-n-s so
every single morning i write down what
my goal is why i want the goal and then
i write down what my most important next
step is to get it done then i put on my
calendar so i'm just very meticulous
about that and it's it's helped a lot in
a lot of areas of life i don't business
you know personal fitness family all
that stuff so i know i'm probably kind
of a weirdo with goals but it works for
me
that's really cool i like it i love the
mints thing that's really cool uh let's
do it on you right now what's the goal
you want to achieve in life
a goal i want to achieve in life we want
to do real estate you want to buy some
rentals
first thing i thought of was uh probably
having a family okay do you have a
girlfriend wife anything like that
no okay uh yeah you wanna we don't get
you a girlfriend we gotta work on that
first date all right so we wanna get one
date what's what's your most important
next step i'm getting a date and getting
getting a date what's the smallest less
than five minute task that you should be
doing to get a
probably finding a girl we can't get
let's get more specific what can you do
probably look better
maybe get a haircut
okay let's go with that let's go save my
neck
what's the what's that
what's the most important next step on
getting a haircut uh what's your
mainline haircut uh looking up or
actually there's a great clips down the
street okay what's your most important
next step for getting a haircut
uh
getting my car and going to great clips
okay would you have to schedule
appointment or anything no okay you just
gotta go yeah okay when are you gonna do
that well i just don't okay oh you're
the the excuse what time are you doing
man you're saying
no you said no you said what's a goal i
want in life okay i wanna have a good
happy family okay but i'm only 23. i
just turned 23. so i think that's
something i want to do but i don't think
that's something that's like a pressing
thing sure okay so maybe that's not the
ideal thing but you get the idea right
like i like that it's like especially
nice like especially if you're like
hammering it out and you know you do
this people pay branded big money for
this you realize people pay brandon like
five grand well here's just just what
he's doing to you right now you follow
along it's super simple though so in
other words this amazing life goal of
like what you want to accomplish is to
have kids and a family like you can
think of how amazing that is it all
comes down to
you just going to great clips right or
whatever super cuts i don't know like
your entire life is is all dependent on
this one simple act of getting a haircut
right now that's it why aren't you
getting a haircut man why are you still
sitting here like go get your hair no
you're right timing it doesn't matter
right right that's good but people are
like hey i want i hate my job i want to
get out of my job i'm like okay well
what's your most important they want oh
i want to buy rental property i want to
get uh 3 000 a month in cash flow great
what's your most important what's most
important next step they're like well i
gotta buy a rental what's your most
important next step uh i gotta find a
real estate agent great what's your most
important next step uh
i gotta go on you know and they'll
they'll usually like oh no right go to
if you go to facebook and ask family and
friends hey does anybody know a good
real estate agent in las vegas
that takes 30 seconds to make that post
do you know a great real estate agent in
las vegas and it'll probably get you
what you want your entire future the
next 80 years of your life enjoying life
having wealth like living an amazing
incredible life all comes down to 30
seconds but you know what people will go
30 years without doing that task it's a
30-second task and they'll go 30 years
without doing it and they'll wake up
with 60 70 years old overweight like you
know divorced four times and they're
like why isn't my life working out
because they didn't do the 30 second
task when they knew they needed to
because they just don't think about it
so i'm i'm really big on this idea like
go work backwards from what you want and
everything is a five minute or less task
so
that was crazy really good holy do that
again yeah do it now
actually graham we're gonna do it to you
right now let's do it let's be fun you
ready so what what's the financial goal
you have you want to buy or do or
gosh a business idea man i want to lower
my taxes okay you want to lower your
taxes great it's great taxes all right
you lower your taxes what are you too
late for this year what's the mo is it
you get two weeks how where uh i don't
know what's your most important next
step to find that answer
i i'm worried about rushing it but uh
i already asked you yeah okay so and you
and you said no i i don't have anything
closing this year yeah i know uh ryan
pineda uh was it was another person but
he uh he didn't have anything closing
this year okay and uh too late on that
so i have two weeks basically
to spend money on something that that i
feel like shouldn't be rushed i feel
like it's probably too late for this
yeah
maybe what's your most important next
step to find out who could you what's
your most important accept that you
could ask who could you ask i could ask
you okay
so when's the next deal that you have
coming up i don't have a deal but
we're just finished we just raised the
fund but you could yeah like can i get
in that fund uh no i don't think so i
think we're full sorry uh
but
i've got a duplex that kurt cobain used
to live in
[Laughter]
no uh but yeah but uh for example i'm
part of a group it's called go abundance
right so it's all millionaires you have
three million dollar plus net worth to
be in it and there's a facebook group
where people post in there so because
you're asking me do i have any
suggestions for you i'd be like well i
could post in there and just say hey i
mean anybody have any ideas i got a
buddy who's looking to whatever so in
less than a five minute task for me i
can post in this group and somebody
might have a deal coming there's
hundreds of real estate investors in the
group that do exactly what i do
so that's an option don't you feel like
it's a bit rushed if i have two weeks to
basically
spend that amount of money yeah and i
don't want to rush a deal unless unless
the perfect thing comes up it's like hey
we got this commercial space
put a million in it and yeah it's just
closing in right in that time yeah um
yeah so i'm kind of screwed not
necessarily
no i don't need ten model i wanted to
build out the other garage
so
could you buy a jet
no grant cardone style i've thought
about so many things no there's just
there's nothing
real estate was the only thing that i
thought would be good but i'm too late
in the air real estate is i introduce
you by the way to my buddy who does the
uh
the what's it called the you buy real
estate and save a lot of money on taxes
because you buy a commercial so you got
an email in there oh but you won't close
by the end of the year on that no i
don't think anyway
let me put some more thought into this
yeah i like i love problems like this
like so there's this thing called
parkinson's law right you've probably
heard it before like work expands to
fill the time you have
like i don't know 10 years ago now i had
this goal set beginning of the year i'm
going to buy this is before i was like
super goal oriented but i was like i
want to buy 12
units this year 12 properties or 12
units right and it was like december
21st
and i counted them up i was just like
driving from the airport and i kind of
forgot the goal again i wasn't doing any
of this journal stuff every day and i
was like counting them up i'm driving
home from the airport and i'm like oh
dang it about 11.
i was like well it was a good try man 11
is pretty close right alone's pretty
good but then i remember like i'm not
somebody who just like gives up
90 of the way there right like i might
as well try so i had 10 days 10 of the
year and two of them are holidays and
one's christmas eve uh and on december
30th i closed on my 12th property like i
closed on it i didn't even have anything
in mind at all and i had you know
whatever ten days or nine days i closed
later it just shows like the power of
like when you have a year to get
something done you'll get done in a year
but if you really want to do it in two
weeks three weeks you'll do it like
there's always a way just
where's the mental you know it's going
to take some mental energy is it worth
it right but that's why i love a problem
like that i love constrained times
like any time you can put something into
a shorter timeline it you'll almost
always get it done in the same amount of
like
effectiveness as if you would have
done it in a longer time so
but let me let me work on that problem
in my head a little bit yeah that's
that's really financially there's really
not much
that's really
i mean you could do a uh i'm not an
expert this but you could do a charity
what's called a charitable remainder
trust here those right like you dump
money into this like trust and then you
can
you get the deduction the year that you
put it in there but you don't have to
give the money in the year that you put
it in there so let's say you throw a
million bucks in this trust and you now
have a million dollar write-off and then
you can figure out over the next few
years where you want to give the money
to but you get it off uh in this year um
i'm actually working on an idea that's
different but similar um carries your
thoughts i'm going to give you guys a
picture right okay this is the idea that
i have i'm thinking so what we do in
real estate like in my company like odc
what we do is we buy these properties
let's call it 50 million dollars for an
apartment building we then
fix it up a little bit over the time
over the next few years we'll raise the
rent slowly
we pay off the mortgage a little bit and
after and by the way we raised the money
from people like you to invest all right
so you give us the money
you're funding the down payment we buy
the property fix it up and we sell it
let's call it seven years later for 80
million dollars we bought it for 50 we
sell it for 80. now we've paid off the
property let's call it 5 million dollars
in that time
so and we pay some closing costs and all
that at the end of the day we clear 30
million bucks we give it back to you and
the hundreds of other people that gave
us money you get a nice return on your
money like yeah that was cool i made
some money and i get some fees and i get
some profit at the end and everybody
wins right but what do we actually do
there like what do we actually do we out
of thin air generated 30 million dollars
just like
now it took seven years to get there but
we made like what other industry can you
with that level of like assurance not
that it's 100 but like
that level of assurance generate 30
million dollars
with relatively not that much work
because like the machine i mean i
already have 3000 units add another 300
on to that
it's not that much extra work for my
company to manage that and
the key then so here's what i want to do
i want to go to guys like you and say
hey
you put in go put in a million bucks
into this fund you're going to get your
million dollars back whenever we sell
the property but you put the million
dollars in now you get a zero percent
return on your money
and you get your money back at the end
because we're going to take a 50 million
property and turn into an 80 million
property and we're going to get 30
million dollars to kids that don't have
food over in some country right look at
the massive good you could do in that
case but here's what's cool
you who just donated let's say a million
dollars
you your million dollars would have
turned into three or four million
dollars over that time
there may be a way and i'm still working
through the
logistics of this that you can write off
the three to four million dollars in the
year that you give it so you give me the
million dollars today and you take a
three million dollar loss well isn't
that what uh what they're doing with the
i forget what they the stock account is
called the yeah i don't know yeah i
think they're already doing it with
stocks where you could you you would
throw your money into an investment
account that's specifically meant for
charity and then you're able to donate
the full amount to that account so if it
goes from one to five you're able to
donate the five yeah i think that so
similar thing just doing it with real
estate uh and i'm like when i thought of
this i started putting together with
some other real estate investors were
like oh shoot like this could like like
because now all of a sudden you make
money by giving donating money like
right away like you offset your money
off of your income now you maybe we
can't do it in the year of i think we
can though but even if not okay fine you
get the deduction five million dollars
whatever down the road who cares i think
a lot of wealthy people would feel
really good then every quarter instead
of like a quarterly report you get
quarterly life saved like hey this year
we saved you know this quarter we saved
45 kids from malaria good job thanks for
your support that would make everyone
feel so good and then the tax benefits
come in and so anyway that's one thing
i'm gonna be working on this year my
little sabbatical is thinking through
how do i make that a thing like that and
if we treat all of our like
um life like that like
just always thinking like what do i
gotta do next like what's the most
important next thing and then you do it
and then you ask yourself again and
again and again and it's just it's
incredible how fast you can go through
life but what we do
i call it dead space it's the time
between taking actions on any project
like how long it take to read a book
like if you were just pick up a new
business book you'd probably read in
what a couple weeks maybe
but are you a really slow reader like
that's like one word a minute you know
like the reality is we read for an hour
we wait for a day we read for 10 minutes
we wait for a couple days but what if
you read every hour for five minutes you
get it done in a couple of couple days
you read every if you read 45 minutes
every hour you get done in an afternoon
so the idea is like you want to minimize
that dead space and the things that
really matter in life is just shorten
that time
so instead of taking action once a month
you take action every single day even if
it's just a little bit a little five
minute task so i'm i'm really so
motivational
dude
it is life-changing stuff right it's
just it's the difference between like so
many people live their entire life like
they're in the backseat of a cab like
they like their life is driving and
they're in the back seat just like on
their phone like swiping and like not
really sure where their life's going
it's just like falling where it wants to
go but then at some point in your life
you can realize like hey like
there is no cab driver like it's just
like
driving all over the place like
automatic i can get in the front seat
and i can drive and i can choose where
i'm going and i can choose the direction
i'm going to take to get there
and this is like almost every like uber
successful person i know they all live
their life this exact same way they know
where they're going and they
they work toward it and things change
all the time right like road
construction pops up but you're driving
so you swerve around and you figure out
another way and you ask how am i gonna
get past it and uh yeah i'm so
passionate about this idea of like take
control of your life and like yeah
there's too much misery in the world you
know and and people just like miserable
because
they're just letting life take them not
you guys though you guys are crushing it
you guys are crazy i'm all amped up now
and i don't want to drink some more
coffee five o'clock in the morning i'm
gonna go to the gym i'm gonna do all
these things well how many people have
you know like you're like oh i'm like i
want to lose weight right like i went to
the gym on monday and then i didn't i
didn't lose any weight so i haven't been
back in a week and you're just like like
it's not about going once right it's
about going every day yeah so yeah you
can't complain about being out of shape
or overweight or anything like that
because you have a choice to change it
right from most people so all right i
want to know now what is your opinion on
the real estate market as a whole
and uh any advice that you may have for
me in my current position i spoke to
kevin about this because i i just closed
it like i told you before the podcast on
my first property october 11th and now
i'm like okay i kind of want to get
another property the only issue is i
don't want to move in to a new property
like i'm so content in my current place
like we strung up lights i have a ping
pong room it's gravy it is so nice
but i do want the lower interest rate
the fha loan that one like live in one
of the units it's only one of a dozen
plus strategies that i i'm like not not
to plug a book but i wrote a book like
six years ago my first one i was on how
to invest in real estate with no and low
money down like it's literally like
here's a bunch of different ways you can
invest in real estate with no money and
the fha the house hacking thing is just
one of those ways and it's not even a
good one because it's not zero down it's
three and a half percent down like
there's gonna be about 25
then just go get a 25 loan on investment
property and you don't have to worry
about the fine yeah totally fine you can
get 20 to 25 down loans all day long
uh so that's definitely if you have the
money
all day long just go get a rental
property now
get the right rental property right
that's not just like go buy a property
in fact i
i did an interview for business insider
recently did you did i tell you about
that one i did this interview for
business insider and it's a big site and
i i was worried
that it wasn't going to be a friendly
interview even though it's a business
thing but they started interviewing a
lot of other they're trying to get a
hold of me and i just kind of like blew
it off for a while and i started
interviewing all these other people
around me and people call me like hey i
just had to talk with business insider
they want to know all about you and what
you're doing and all that and i was like
that doesn't sound good but then i
figured might as well i i might as well
like hear the guy out and figure out
what they're talking about so they write
this article about me
i talked to the journalist for like an
hour and a half
and
in there i just a conversation like this
was like i just tell them what i like
about real estate where the market's
headed and i'll come back to your
question by the way i didn't totally
forget it anyway and
in there i said
you can't just go and buy any random
property on the mls like the where all
the properties are for sale and then
hope to make money like that was like
2010 right you just buy anything back
then it made money you got to know what
you're doing you gotta like run some
numbers like it's it's one in a hundred
deals are actually probably good enough
to make money so you just gotta get you
know learn how to do it it's a learnable
process
and so the quote like the the the
headline was something like brandon
turner makes millions selling dreams
but he doesn't even believe in real
estate like that was what they that's
that's the quote they took and they said
he says if you buy a property right now
you'll lose money that was that's what
they took from that was because i said
if you buy any random property you're
going to lose money so if you buy any
random property you're going to lose
money unless you know what you're doing
a little bit right so
and they by the way the picture they
took for that like they took a picture
like they put my face on that article
they put a gold tooth that like shot no
you look it up it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous what is it yeah business just
happened to go to google have like
business insider brandon turner makes
millions
uh oh my gosh isn't that great that's it
brandon turner makes millions selling
real estate investing dreams yeah yeah
even he says you'll lose money right can
you not uh because
from my experience oh you spoke with
what is this daniel yeah i think so from
my experience with business insider they
want people to come back
it doesn't make any sense if you're
unhappy with this that they wouldn't
change it yeah well it would ask him to
change i sent an email i was like that
wasn't interesting because i'm here's
what media does today right media like
somebody writes an article article's
actually pretty decent there's a little
bit of criticism what not necessarily
criticism of what i do but more like
questioning like
like why are people giving influencers
money that was the kind of question they
pose in there but most of it's a pretty
like actual factual good article
then some editor or the um
some guy in charge changes the headline
because they want clicks right they're
like oh brandon turner's got a big name
let's make it controversial and they put
it out there so i emailed the guy i'm
like well that was an interesting choice
for a title
i actually would have shared the article
all over and so would bigger pockets
which you know have a big reach we would
have talked about it all over had you
not given me a shiny tooth and and and
made me look like a [ __ ] yeah and you
have never wrote back so i'm like maybe
you have a phone number to call no i
just left it i'm like they deliberately
like it was a it was a smear
article uh and again the question like
that they kind of pose is like
i mean we've raised a hundred million
dollars from accredited investors so all
rich people like it's not like i'm
taking money from grandma we raised a
hundred million dollars from people in
the last year and a half and use that to
buy 300 million dollars with a real
estate and they're saying like i mean
that's unheard of like back in the day
to raise money you had to go to every
conference you had to wear a suit and a
tie you had to
like do this game and it was all like
who you knew and you had to make a dozen
pitches every day and do big long
webinars i mean it was and i still know
guys that do that like they just work so
incredibly hard to raise a few million
bucks and then here i am like on
instagram and was like in my flip-flops
and doing stupid videos of me dancing to
my kitchen to punk rock and i'm like oh
by the way i'm raising some money and
then people are like yeah take mine
right and that article is like how is
that a thing like this guy just could
not believe that's a thing that people
do
and the truth is like they do it because
they know like and trust me
and this is the secret to raising money
is like when you can get people to know
like and trust you at scale
like they understand that i'm not going
to take their money and run because they
know that i'm a father they know where i
live they know that they've heard me for
500 hours on a podcast
so they're like yeah i would trust that
guy with my money and they've heard me
talk and they know that i can
intelligently talk about the pros and
cons of real estate and why i like it
and what goes you know
so
real estate investing has changed
dramatically over the past few years in
that ability to raise money via social
media
and uh i'm kind of one of the guys at
the forefront i mean of course grant
cardone is
so much farther ahead than i am on that
i mean he's raised like a billion or two
or three now i don't know he's raised a
ton but uh it's fascinating this idea of
taking
like this kind of niche celebrity world
that we're in
and then using that to to raise money to
then buy big real estate deals and then
you take a piece it's private equity
it's just that scale so anyway
back to your question
real estate market where's it going yeah
yeah down the toilet no just kidding uh
brandon turner makes millions yeah uh
i think of course we have no idea right
a couple of thoughts one
i don't care into some level i don't
really care that much because
if the market goes down
i will just buy more real estate it's
great like it's actually going to be a
good thing if real estate goes down in
price i'll buy more because we buy for
cash flow like we buy properties that
make money today i do not expect rent to
drop and even if it did it could drop 20
percent before we even break even
because you know what bank won't like if
you're buying a commercial loan a bank
won't even give you a loan if you're not
making 20 margins like that's like their
number 20 or 25 so like we rents could
drop 25
before we're breaking even uh and that's
all i mean rents don't typically drop
even an 08 they didn't drop and and with
the amount of money that the
government's printing right now there's
not a lot of people out there thinking
that we're going to see lower rents and
lower real estate prices almost
everybody i know
says the same thing that rents will
likely continue to climb uh there's been
a housing shortage in america that's
only getting worse and worse they're not
they're not building
as many houses as there are people
coming into the country and wanting and
wanting to live supply and demand says
again that's going to drive up rents
even higher so i don't worry too much
about the rent so as long as i buy
properties that make money today i'm
okay if the market drops it doesn't
matter you have a mortgage like
my property could go to zero it doesn't
matter i just like eventually going back
up again again real estate tends to
up and down there all right that said
uh i i think it's gonna keep going up i
think we're gonna see a lot more like
turn into europe you know like in europe
it wouldn't be a normal thing the
kind of real estate cash flow that we
have like in america is not normal in
the rest of the world like you don't
just go and like buy a property for 20
down and start making hundreds of
dollars a month in cash flow that's not
a thing in most countries um like for
example hawaii is probably more similar
to what a lot of europe is where the
house costs a million dollars and it
rents for two thousand dollars a month
versus you can buy a house in ohio for a
hundred thousand dollars and it runs for
two thousand dollars a month like that's
it's like
ten times more profitable than it is in
europe so i think we're just going to
become more and more like europe and
more like canada
which has been like just crazy expensive
and
in which case great all our properties
go up and up and up so buy properties
that make sense now
run the numbers learn how to run those
numbers and account for things like we
talked about earlier capex right things
will break that pipe at your house
that's just
you know what's going to happen so if
you're setting aside 300 bucks a month
for capex that's 3 600 a year every
every other year you could spend seven
grand on some repair
and it's like okay no problem if you
have a problem and money can fix it and
you have the money you don't have a
problem yeah it's just business
how do you feel about people
villainizing landlords yeah because it
does seem and we were talking about this
the other day that we're moving in the
direction right now where if you're a
landlord you're bad yes because housing
is a human right and just like you
wouldn't gouge someone for food uh
people need a place to live and as a
landlord you're profiting on that yeah
so there's seem it's we're going in that
direction i don't think we i i don't
think we've seen the worst of it yet
yeah and i think it's unfortunately i
think it's going to continue i'd assume
and to uh until a point where you could
no longer say you're a landlord the
biggest risk that i think we have in
real estate today is and this is not a
political it is a political thing but it
it is if
somebody likes like bernie or aoc gets
in charge
and then do something like you know what
like housing is a right so we're gonna
take all rent in america and drop it in
half like if that like i doubt that'll
happen and i think there's a lot
of smart people in that sounds
ridiculous but in washington who would
make sure that didn't happen and they
would say no that's going to destroy the
world but that is i think the biggest
risk we have is that housing gets so
expensive because the government's just
printing some money so all of a sudden
rent goes from a thousand to two
thousand to three thousand and jobs
aren't keeping up
then the government might step in and
institute rent control or start dropping
rents but like they're not going to
bankrupt every landlord in america
because then for everything is
foreclosed on and they completely tank
the economy so i don't expect that i
think it's a one in a thousand shot but
that is the biggest risk we have is that
somebody comes in i mean there was a
uh oh was it you tell me this or
somebody else there's a city council
person like seattle who was like
fighting to say like every like every
landlord was going to have to give
equity and ownership to every one of
their tenants that was just a thing
because tenants deserve to own where
they live and it's like okay well are
they going to pay their share of the
roof when it breaks and are they going
to pay their share of the pipe that
broke in front yard like who's paying
that money like there's a reason
landlords make money now the other
reason i don't worry too much from a
political side is that most i don't know
if most of the numbers but many many
many of the senators and congress people
in our world they own real estate
most of the rich people in the u.s own
real estate
it's
they're not going to screw themselves
but
from my yeah yeah
it can be like a cop yeah
people want to get elected yes i think
it's moving in that direction where you
can't say hey guys we want to be
financially literate and let's save our
money
it's a lot easier to say let's cancel
student loan debt yeah i agree
college should be free let's tax the
people making a little bit more than you
uh that's not fair and uh i think those
are the people more likely to get votes
and over time it's slowly gonna switch
i also wouldn't be surprised if at some
point we we have a nationwide uh rent
control at some point where it's like
hey you can't raise the rent more than
three percent here here are these terms
or
they they basically say to people you
cannot own more than five properties you
have a main residence a vacation home
and three rentals and that's it or if
you're married well now it's 10
properties that you could own between
the two of you something like that and
then once you reach your 10th property
uh you know then it's like well now you
got to sell one of them to buy something
else or maybe they start progressively
taxing it like after five properties
then you pay a sur tax on that six
property like like an extra 10 or
something like that yeah i just i just
think that there will always be a way to
outsmart politicians like always like
there's so many rules today that were
like years ago we're like no i can't
believe you made that rule and then like
okay we're gonna start an llc and
they're gonna own the property i don't
know what it like this company does and
you wrap it in this company and you put
it in here there's all like
there's you always find ways to outsmart
the politicians and
uh and this is maybe this is a problem
with uh a democracy and capitalism but
the people who have money and are well
educated they can afford the lawyers and
the people to get around the laws and so
then they do and they make even more
money and the people that don't get hurt
by those rules which is why i think a
huge problem in california like i don't
think rent control
i think rent control led to the prices
going crazy in california it didn't stop
it it led to it right i think anytime
they try to curtail free market
it tends to hurt the people at the
bottom of the market i think and so if
they stop nationwide rent control we
would all shift how we do things a
little bit we'd all keep watching
youtube videos and learning and growing
and we'd figure out a way around it we
figured a way to make money and we'd do
even better and then the people would
get more screwed at the bottom like i
got to tell you i'm really upset i mean
this it is what it is but my place in
west la
um the rent control is so strict there
that the maximum you could raise your
rent
is 54 a year
that's it and the place would probably
rent for all in like 10 grand a month
and 54 a year so my property tax goes up
higher than my rent increase on the
property it's better for me to leave it
empty and just so i have a place to come
back to you know every few weekends
spend a weekend there it's better for me
to leave it empty than rent it because
it's it's so difficult to get a tenant
out and i just
wouldn't make sense yeah yeah i can see
that there's also what happens too is
people shift right they're gonna shift
like texas will never institute rent
control right it's texas uh oklahoma is
never gonna institute rent control these
like these like conservative states just
i can't imagine them doing it
therefore like people just shift there i
mean and those who want to tackle the
problems of rent control there's ways to
make money on that too they're gonna do
that too so i i'm very much an optimist
that i will always figure out a way
around whatever's coming and i think
when we take that perspective
like it's just it's still framed just
like oh yeah like they can't take away
my ability to learn and to grow and to
network and to
figure things out and
i don't know
i just i worry that people have to do
what's popular for the vote and if
eighty percent of people are in favor
for something yes even if it's wrong
even if it's wrong yeah uh financially
i'm not saying you know their beliefs
are on but but if if that would lead to
higher housing prices and they're just
unaware
it's really difficult to explain but
if if it's popular to say hey
uh we need more rent control yep then
that's what's going to get voted in yep
i mean what are your thoughts on
inflation right now the money printing i
mean you're smarter
personally i don't think i don't think
it's real inflation i think it's a lot
of supply chain issues and bottlenecks
so that's why um what was it i think it
was google
uh refused to give their
employees a raise based on the inflation
readings and i think google is smart
enough to know that if inflation goes up
seven percent uh
you know
this isn't a permanent thing that's
going to last another 10 years so
they're like why are we gonna increase
wages seven percent when this could go
down three years from now and then what
we're not gonna bring down their wages
so what if we see deflation then we
could pay less no
so
i i think it's probably another two
years where we're gonna see you know
crazy high prices but i think probably
another two years i i would say the
biggest risk is if another variant comes
in
which is uh more contagious and and more
severe in terms like it seems like the
the omicron or omicron or however we
pronounce it um
was it
it kind of blew over yeah but if
something similar to that comes up or
it's like oh crap well we we have to
dial things back now that's probably the
only thing that would risk in inflation
but i think it's a supply chain yeah i
think it's what do i think it's causing
i mean that we sat in like lumber like
you know two by four went from like five
dollars to 10 to 15. right to 20 down to
like seven and right now it's back at
like seven or five or whatever like yeah
it moved in the supply chain so i'm sure
that accounted in there and they call it
inflation it's not quite but yeah i mean
my limited understanding of economics
like just says that you can't
you can't print the amount of money that
they're doing without expecting some
inflation in the future right and and
also the amount of money that they keep
giving tenants to pay their rent and if
another variant does come it just comes
to us anyway like the landlords for the
reason why they don't like us
including like now my buddy david's
always telling me telling me and
everyone else to stop talking about the
tax benefits of real estate he's like we
don't want them to know like like the
more we talk about that the more angry
they're going to get when they realize
like what we're doing it's not illegal
and it's encouraged that they like the
government wants us to buy big pieces of
real estate to provide housing and so
they give us a really good tax deduction
on that like all the accelerated
appreciation all that but david's like
if the masses knew what we were doing
you know what no and the reason why they
wouldn't care they care more about you
losing money
the most popular real estate investor of
all time lost it's a fraud
he loses money they love you yeah they
love you know that gets more clicks than
ah this tax loophole people care more
about how we lost money yeah i lost uh i
lost three million dollars last year
on paper i lost three million dollars
and uh therefore because i'm a real
estate professional it offsets all my
income and so
uh it's really sad actually
see that's what that's what david has
you could carry that forward into future
years so now if you make three million
dollars the next year yeah profit now
you have nothing yep it's crazy the the
tax benefits of real estate like when i
look at real estate i'm like here's what
here's why i love it i mean there's bus
business is great i love business it's
great for making money too but real
estate has like these kind of five
things that are going for it right
there's cash flow which is awesome you
buy a property makes extra money every
month every year hopefully you buy the
right one right you get appreciation it
goes up in value over time that's just
how real estate tends to go three
percent on average per year over the
last hundred years
uh and then there's the loan gets paid
down so you buy the property at a
hundred thousand next year only 99.
that's 98 and it's 96.
uh so
loan paid out yo and then the uh so
we're at cash flow appreciation loan pay
down the tax benefits which we touched
on
where you get these losses that aren't
actually losses just on paper they're
losses and so you can deduct your other
income from it
and then the last piece is the leverage
you can buy a million dollar property
for 35 you know 35 000 if you're putting
three and a half percent down
so you include all five of those things
and it's just like
really really good and it has been let's
say you want to open up you had an idea
you're like i want to do a catwalking
business catwalking that's the future i
think it's going to work and so you go
and build your catwalking business you
have no idea if that's gonna work you've
never met another catwalking person you
don't know but you think it's a good
idea and you try it and that's why
ninety percent of businesses fail right
but real estate like you're like i'm
gonna buy a duplex you can go buy a
hundred books on exactly step by step
how to do it you can listen to 550
episodes of the podcast where i tell you
how to buy a duplex it is so documented
and formulaic that it's kind of hard to
screw it up if you if you just take the
education so that's why i like real
estate so much is it's like anybody can
do it you want to be good you don't be
smart you don't have to have money
there's a million strategies but it's
all been so well done that you can
figure it out if you want it
it's there
you're the first person to really get me
hyped now i'm hyped on real estate again
real estate's so good let me get you
even more hyped right so here's here's
why i love real estate even more
so real i call this the stack right so
the stack think of it this way
you're gonna buy i said earlier if i can
make a hundred dollars a month on a unit
like one let's say one house i want to
make 100 bucks in profit after all the
bill's been paid including setting aside
money for repairs and cap capex and
mortgage insurance all that stuff
i want to make a hundred dollars well
you're like that's stupid i mean i can
go make a youtube video make 100 bucks
right i go and sell girl scout cookies
and make a hundred dollars i'm like yeah
you're right and that's a lot of work to
buy 100 to buy one house you have to
learn all this new stuff and these lit
this lingo and all this effort to buy a
hundred dollars but then you take that
knowledge you just learn and you're like
okay i'm gonna buy duplex now and so you
buy the two unit property and now
instead of making a hundred dollars
you're making 200 plus the original
hundred you had right now you got 300 a
month again like you could sell girl
scout cookies for that then the next
next you go buy a fourplex
and then you buy an eight unit after
that then you buy 20 unit after that
and now all of a sudden now you're like
well i'm making you know four grand a
month in money and then you buy the uh i
don't know what is that 20 unit 40 unit
let me buy the 80 unit now this is you
must be formulaic like that but the idea
is exponential growth right
so
up until three years ago uh i had a
hundred units it took me it took me 12
years to get a hundred rental units
it took me
well i mean like really two years i
bought my first like big one two years
ago now two years and two weeks ago so
it took me what's that whatever
13 years to get to 100 units it took me
two more years to get the 3000 it's just
this
hockey stick and the interesting thing
is i just bought a 72 million dollar i
think we closed tomorrow 72 million
apartment complex down in houston
that property
was less work for me
it's less i would say almost less it's
less risk less money from me than my
very first single family house i bought
15 years ago i wanted i should have
gotten in i should have gotten it out
that was that's good when did you close
the funding on that uh like a month ago
maybe we raised it quickly
yeah so that was like i was like a week
or two or two probably probably probably
couple weeks later
it raises the money raises quick because
a lot of people are in the same
situation especially end of the year
it's a good time to raise like next year
i want to like i'm going to raise like a
ton of money in december because
everyone's like we gotta we gotta deploy
now right
uh
but anyway
yeah it's uh it's it's powerful stuff
and so
the knowledge and education
that's what's important that's why
earlier to circle back those early deals
in in washington when i washington state
i had the 30 units like they're
i value them so much because they got me
to work where i could then
get to the next level
they they matter so much but they also
don't matter at all like financially
speaking like i make a few thousand
dollars a month off it it's nothing
compared to what i make off everything
else
but i couldn't have gotten to the other
part the business of real estate if i
hadn't gone through that this is where i
differ with grant cardone grant cardone
is like start with a 50 unit start there
that's what you should buy and i'm like
ah like when i bought my first 50 unit i
made so many mistakes and i've been
doing it for 10 years or 15 years so i
think you've got to go through the
journey
of buying these smaller deals and you've
done it now right so you're like you've
done the the property thing now you
could probably take down a 20 unit in
your head you're like well
you know it's not really worth my time
to buy a 20 unit you're right
it's financially it's not worth it but
by buying the 20 unit it makes you
better to buy the 100 unit and then
buying 100 unit makes you better to buy
the 500 unit and that's where things get
fun where you're taking a
50 70 million dollar property you're
gonna turn into 120 million dollars
and at that level you've got a whole
team that runs everything for you and
you're just using your your platform to
raise money you just do commercial real
estate was probably like what it is but
would you do that and buy like a jiffy
lube or something like that yeah i would
so i like they call those triple
networks right and and and i can't
remember what it stands for but uh it
basically means yeah there's there's
they're great in that what is it net
taxes yeah
yeah tax insurance and repairs right
yeah so basically you don't have to do
anything man this is you know about this
stuff it's super cool right
you buy a jiffy lube and your only
expense
is your mortgage payment yep right
because they take care of everything
uh it's it's a good idea but here's
what's wrong with that or that what's
scary jiffy lube leaves they go to
business right like um forever people
are like walgreens and cvs they are the
thing to buy because they are never
leaving and then like cbs announced a
couple days ago right it was like
they're closing 900 stores
like
they're like walgreens and cvs will be
out of business in five years or at
least like heavily diminished why
because amazon right so the problem with
triple net lease in my mind is a lot of
them are single asset meaning they're
one tenant in one location and if they
leave you're gonna have a year two years
three years if just an empty property
and it's gonna cost you half a million
dollars just to renovate it for the next
guy and then they might stay for five
years so i'm not saying you can't do
that it's a good model it's just there's
risk there
and so there's also what i like to do is
value ad real estate so we will buy it
at the apartment for 70 million dollars
and we'll put 5 million into a paint and
and remodel in the units and make it
really nice and immediately now it's
worth 90. like just by doing that
remodel and raising the rent now it's
worth way more right away
the jiffy lube you buy it for 5 million
tomorrow it's worth 5 million dollars
and you know 5.1 million sure and it
goes up slowly so versus this and so i
like to the stair-step method it's like
you boom jump up equity and then you go
for a while which is fun so again
different strokes different folks like i
can i can find a millionaire real estate
investor in every single solitary niche
of real estate you'd be like i think
it'd be really cool to own like sober
living houses
and you're like okay i can find you a
millionaire i know a millionaire who's a
millionaire doing sober living houses i
really want to do like
commercial real estate like strip malls
great you can do it all it all works
every bit of it works if you're willing
to put in the time to become great at it
and most people aren't so that's why
they don't
those sober living facilities by the way
i represented a client who would uh he
didn't own the buildings but he would
rent them out
and then create a sober living facility
in what is that
so uh so they would look for so let's
say he would find like an eight-bedroom
house that was 10 grand a month
he would run a facility where people
would pay
five thousand dollars a month or four
thousand dollars a month to live in this
house and they do that i think they do
like meals they do counseling they uh
they they oversee these people and so if
eight people are living in there each
paying five grand a month that's forty
thousand dollars a month his cost is
let's say ten thousand dollars a month
for the house plus another ten thousand
dollars a month for for services so
they're walking away with twenty
thousand dollars a month in profit per
house that they get yeah there's it's
it's all
could be a lot of money yeah there's
there's all these cool little niches in
real estate too which are fun like for
example um one thing i'm going to be
pursuing a little bit in the future on
maui i've got this rental house there
with four bedrooms
and um it was a triplex when i bought it
and then the government stepped in in
maui and they were like we don't want
you to have a tr it's not legally a
triplex take it back to a single family
house and i'm like
dealing with them trying to navigate
that and sure enough i'm gonna have to
take it back to a single family house it
just sucks that's one of the things you
go with right so i'm like all right well
the big thing right now is traveling
nurses especially because of covert but
just in general that's always been a
thing traveling nurses and they need a
place to stay for six months typically
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
turn each bedroom and they're huge
bedrooms in this place each bedroom into
a uh like furnished rental for traveling
nurses and it's i can probably get two
thousand dollars out of each bedroom for
that's two four six eight thousand
dollars a month out of this property i
mean i gotta pay 500 in water and sewer
and garbage and electricity
but that property is going to just like
print money my mortgage is 2 000 a month
and i'm going to have maybe you know
let's call it two more thousand dollars
of all expenses including capex and
management and all that i'll still make
four grand a month and just profit off
that like that's a cool little niche
it's like you could do that you can do
an old folks home i don't think they
call them that's probably the wrong
terminology
senior senior living yeah yeah you can
assisted living now you can do that
there are others they make money too so
i represented a client who did sober
living facilities and senior care
facilities
gosh this guy like a
ton of money doing this the senior care
especially yeah there's
like 30 sometimes a year yeah it's crazy
it's really good uh one one other like
yeah i mean there's a million there's
vacation rentals right like you could be
in an area there's a vacation rental
you've heard of uh airbnb arbitrage that
concept it's like rent to property yeah
you rent a property then you rent on
airbnb i know some people killing it on
that uh it's just
what uh what i would say is like follow
the fire like something like when when
you listen to a real estate podcast or
really any podcast right there something
like fires you up when i when i hear
about bitcoin and people start talking
about bitcoin like i'm just like
dead like nothing i just don't care like
i just it for whatever reason i don't
care
uh i'm sure it's a good idea i mean i
bought like 10 grand just to have it as
a lottery ticket is it maybe go up and
maybe it won't uh but like i just don't
care about it i don't care about crypto
really at all i don't care about nfts
but you talked to me about duplexes ever
since i was 21 i'm like oh let's talk
about duplexes i love them like there's
and then i got into mobile home parks
why
i don't know like some piece of my brain
is miswired and it's like mobile home
parks are cool so i always say like
follow that fire like i don't care what
it is but like everybody gets fired up
about something could be sober living
houses i got a friend who uh was a
severe drug addict uh her husband both
were severe drug addicts and alcoholics
and just struggled that for a long time
and then they like changed their life
like came to jesus like
turned everything around and now they do
sober living houses and like it's such a
cool thing that it fires them up because
it like they went through it and they
saw the yeah follow the fire like
whatever you're like i mean youtube
obviously fires you up so you lean into
it and you're what do you know you're
successful with it because you followed
the fire yeah that's cool now i'm
curious what's your experience been with
mobile home parks uh let me tell you a
story about a bank robber and a
prostitute okay all right uh let's start
with a bank robber walks into a bar yes
we'll start with a prostitute who's
actually not a prostitute so
we got a call uh we had a call to our
property manager my very first mobile
home park i ever bought i get a call
uh well the property manager gets a call
from this gentleman they left the
message of the middle knight and the guy
says i wish i had the recording that
played it's so funny i was like hey
my name's uh well i'm not gonna tell you
my name for obvious reasons and uh i was
over at uh you know whatever park you
know unit number 12 and
went in there and uh met the lady on
through craigslist and i went in there
and i paid the lady or money and i took
off my clothes and i laid in the bed
then her boyfriend comes in and rob me
i'm not going to the cops with this so i
just wanted you to know and so no
prostitute
who actually was a thief which is a cool
because that's actually the perfect
crime right what's this guy going to do
like
yeah so for uh those who want to make
some good money let me tell you a great
strategy
yeah isn't that crazy yeah it's like
robbing a uh a thief but in that way
without someone in your trailer in my
trailer park now we buy nicer trailer
parks we try to than that but like so
that's first story the second one a
little more boring the guy robbed a bank
and then fled and fbi was after him and
we had to repossess both anyway the
first lady she left after like a month
after that uh you know it was just
hearsay we actually didn't know she was
a thief it's just some random guy calls
right i'm sure she was but i'm not gonna
evict the lady because somebody said
that obviously we watched closer the
bank robber we had to repossess his
house after a while
so
mobile home parks are fun they they're
good for stories but really they're good
for cash flow they make they make good
money and here's why i like them so much
if you buy
a rental house sorry let's go apartment
you buy an apartment complex and
the plumbing breaks the toilet breaks
because the tenant flushed a contact
lens bottle down the toilet true story
then i go over and i have to pay
somebody to go and fix that but in my in
my mobile home parks if a tenant drops a
contact
bottle down the sink they have to pay
that it's their home like i don't own
the home they own their own home
so i don't
have to deal with the ups and downs of
dealing with repairs and contractors and
all that drama
now there is an aspect of that because
we bring in a lot of homes but that's
what my favorite thing is like it it's
fairly stabilized cash flow like it's
like triple not least in a way because i
don't have to deal with the repairs
maintenance or any of that just like
they pay rent they even pay their own
water bill and so my expenses and the
headache is pretty low plus because they
own their own home on my land
they don't typically leave they'll stay
for years and years and years because
they can't just move their house it's
expensive and i you know there's some
investors who have like gloated over it
over the years like like you know yeah
that we trapped them in our park and
like i don't i don't want to think that
way like i don't but it's kind of true
right like in a way they they are
low-income they can't just pay 10 000 to
move their home to another park and so
they kind of are stuck there uh now some
people say that's then you shouldn't do
mobile home parks it's immoral to do
that i'm like well i mean there's people
at that level so they can be
they can have crappy landlords that take
advantage of them and treat them
terribly or i can help them it's like
there's going to be low-income people
everywhere so i just happen to serve
them and i serve them well and i try to
treat them we don't jack their rent up
in fact
the other thing i love about mobile home
parks is that
we buy them partially empty i like that
so if you go buy an apartment complex
it's a 100 unit apartment complex and
for some reason they've had a hard time
getting tenants lately they're only
eighty percent full let's just say
you still pay a hundred percent for that
property you still pay as if it was a
hundred percent full that's just how
commercial apartments are
with the mobile home park
if it's only eighty percent full i pay
80 because there's no homes there and
then we are really good at finding homes
moving them and then setting them up and
then selling them to tenants
and so every time you bring in a new
home i can take a property from 70 or 60
full up to 100 full and then at the same
time i can shift the water bill over to
their responsibility i can manage it
better get better and get more people
paying rent on time because i'm actually
a good property manager
and all of a sudden i've doubled the
value of that park in a short time in
fact our very first fund with my company
we bought a three mobile home parks
total price was six million dollars 6.1
we just sold it for 13. like in two
years we went from 6 million to 13.
our investors got a stupid good return
on that one and we won't get that i'm
sure every deal in the hill in the
future but that's what's fun about
mobile home parks plus the stories the
bank robbers and the prospects what's
the return that you usually get on a
mobile home park
uh 30 20. i mean so the deal that first
one uh we ended up uh we our investors
who got who they get roughly 70 give or
take of of the deal we as a company that
owns it we take about 30. so they got
like a 35 return on their money like per
year like irr they got like a 35 which
is phenomenal i mean we don't usually we
project like 15
to if we can get 20 that's a home run um
but 15 is is good we kind of under we we
say we underwrite to 15
so if we
if we we can determine how much to pay
for a property by working backwards and
saying okay well if our investors need
15 percent
uh you know irr then working backwards
we can pay
6.1 million and that's that's what we
offer there's no emotion there it's just
like this is the numbers if we can make
it work great if not move on to the next
one so it makes me want to invest
what's the qualifications of an
accredited investor isn't it just 250
000 it's like 200 yeah it's 200 if
you're single 300 if you're married or
you have a million dollar net worth or
you have like a series seven that's the
crazy thing nobody checks it's like as
far as i'm aware for a credited investor
all you have to do is self-certified
it's like i'm an accredited investor
yeah yes so yes no that's yes and no so
there's a little distinction here you're
right with this is probably getting into
the weeds that maybe people won't care
about but there's two mainly two types
of syndications there's what's called a
506 b and a 506 c
so a 506 and this is important for you
to know down the road for i'll tell you
what for obvious reasons in a second a
506 b
means it's your friends and it's friends
family people you maybe know have a
connection with you go to conferences
you meet people who shake the hands all
that we talked about earlier almost
everybody does that and has for the last
whatever x amount of years because
to do that you can a
credit investors just have to say
they're accredited and b you can take
money from up to 35 non-accredited so
from like your buddy who makes 180 000 a
year he can give you 50 grand not a big
deal
the other option is to 506c that's what
i do
that one says you have to prove that
they're credited that's you should go
through a process to approve it there's
actually companies out there that will
do that for you costs a few hundred
bucks we pay it and they have to prove
it let's say bank statements all that
right
um and we can only take money from
accredited investors so like why would
we do that like that sounds like the
other option's way better right it's
because with the other option the one
that i don't do you can't advertise you
can't talk about your podcast you can't
put it on a facebook ad you can't put it
anywhere publicly like it's it's very
like you know
in person it's a family friend
so if you are an influencer of any kind
imagine you had a real estate thing and
you could not talk about your real
estate it would suck so the people who
have an audience like me that's why i've
been able to raise so much money is
because i do 506 c it just sucks because
there's i mean there's how many people
watching this right now that would be
like oh yeah that sounds cool to invest
oh i don't make 200 000 a year and so
they can't i wish i could yeah so grant
cardone has a model there's a third one
out there that you can get the best of
both worlds it's just super expensive
and complicated and
leads a lot of headaches like he got
sued you know he got sued by like
somebody who put in like 10 grand like i
don't know the whole story but like
the guy who puts in 10 grand is the guy
who sues you because he's like grant
said i was gonna make 15 of my money and
we only made two percent or whatever
you're like he said 15 irr that means
like spread out over the course of the
investment at the end you get most of it
then
it's always the guys that put in 10
grand that caused you the problems i've
got a few people who put in millions
yeah you never hear from them like
you never because they just yeah they
trust you like so anyway crazy i've
always noticed that in real estate too
generally the people spending the most
wouldn't care just like just give me a
house at this
the easiest deals just what do you want
me to say all right done yep that's it
and and meanwhile the people uh
in the lower price points comb through
everything like you know what my my
father said that this was a bad term we
should cross that out it's like it's a
standard scenario
it's like but no we don't agree with
that once it's always those yeah it's
actually one of the great things when we
raise money we raise a lot of money we
we like we will like tag people as like
they're going to be difficult to work
with like they're the ones that like
they want to go through every single
line and every single thing and like
they'll like look at our documents and
be like
you only have a hundred and thirty four
thousand here for paint uh this seems a
little bit too low i think you're
probably gonna be more like 140 or like
or whatever i'm like listen man like
we've been doing this for a while we've
got contractor bids like you're like an
armchair quarterback maybe this isn't
the right investment for you like we
will like just not take people's money
um and like people will ask me sometimes
like hey uh should i put money with this
guy uh his his his investment that was
gonna sound really bad but i'm gonna say
it anyway when i invest in other
people's syndications i almost never
look at their like
ppm or their information i don't care
because like i i trust them as a person
they're people that i know i like them i
trust them and so like how am i going to
go through their not documenting they
put 100 hours of work into analyzing
this deal am i going to go in there and
be like
i don't like how you put only uh 55
there a month for rent raise i think you
only get 50 like i don't know like do
you trust the person do you think they
have a good chance of making your money
grow and if so i'm going to make the bet
on them and the best i can do is i make
a lot of bets and i think most of them
will pan out because i trust the people
i think that they're trustworthy people
and
it's best you can do so it's like that
was companies right like you invest in a
stock because you like the company like
i think they then they got legs jack did
you sell robin hood yet no it was down
again jack so just so this is what
happens i invest a big chunk of money
into robin hood and then jack over here
is like dude
why
and he buys it in the stock tanks oh
it's every single time
and it keeps dropping and i keep telling
you joe just go sell it he's like no
it's gonna go up is but the longer you
wait to sell the lower the price goes
please and this is why i love real
estate that strategy works you love your
real estate that works really good in
real estate like if it drops you're like
oh let's hang on till it comes back you
can't do that in stock you can do it in
real time i was where i was going to
crash the las vegas market as soon as he
is it foreclosures like yeah yeah you're
the guy in like school where you like
walk by the computer lab i don't know if
they had computer labs when you're in
school we walk by and like all the
computers just like shut down you're
like just the bad luck guy jackie
absolutely not no i'm riding this out
ride it out man this is one of his
heaviest positions too it's just so
unfortunate that i happen to buy into it
what jack what if i give you 500 bucks
right now
dude i can't what if
what if you arm wrestles for right now
no jack's gonna win yeah we aren't
messed with last podcast really by the
way my arm was hurting the next day oh
mine wasn't
i won but yeah so jack five hundred
dollars i'll say seriously because i
want i have so much money invested in
this that for me 500 bucks it's worth it
just to get checked out dude and when do
i buy back in 30 days three days
i'll heavily consider it tomorrow
i'll talk about it it's market closed
anyways and tomorrow's saturday so it's
not like we have you could rock paper
scissors it all right how about this
rock paper scissors if you win you pay
me 500
and i'll sell and i'll buy back in 30
calendar days from the day i sell if i
win
we'll leave it
okay
about this 250
250 375.
300
350. 300 i'll buy dinner tonight
i'm not hungry 300 300
all right 300 and a dinner credit
super sushi
you already owe me one super sushi so
we're back at two
okay so now we have to rock paper
scissors rock paper scissors
rock paper scissors okay so you got the
first one
you write one okay okay
rock paper scissors
oh
see well no
no
see and i told you monday green candling
okay 300 bucks man green candles you
just are you're having bad luck with
this stock not only are you down 80
grand now you lost 300 more greens i
know you didn't lose money you're right
you're right you're right how much can i
pay you for your stock picks man okay
you're lucky
so i could short them
just open up a short position as soon as
you buy it fake me out and then short
the stock immediately afterwards
crap sorry man wow
all right it's it's gonna go good that's
so exciting
it's a good moment what uh we should
probably wrap up here if you have any
questions for us
uh i wanna know when you're gonna buy
your next piece of real estate
open the fund up i i want to invest in
your funds seriously okay that's
what i'm waiting the truth is most
people okay so let me tell you a quick
story yeah it was a good good ending
here for you guys
when i once bought a property at auction
for fifteen thousand dollars fifty one
five right super cheap i researched it
uh it came out for auction nobody else
showed up the bid and they're like
opening a bit like they're we're
standing in like the lobby of the
courthouse and like opening bed is
fifteen thousand one hundred and twelve
and i was like fifteen thousand one
hundred thirteen i get it right i then
go remodel the property i spent like i
don't know 25 grand something like that
it took like nine months to fix it up
super annoying uh finally get it fixed
up and done i put on airbnb for a while
it was kind of cool super stressful like
people couldn't get the front door open
because they didn't know how to use a
keypad and like that's the annoyance
with airbnb got tired of that put a
regular tenant in it
that was annoying for a little while up
and up and down finally sold the
property after like four years of owning
it and i and i look at my numbers i
averaged it all out put a spreadsheet
and i made a 15 return on my money
and i'm like that was when i realized it
was like that moment i was like
i could have just given my money to
somebody else and gotten the same return
right now that it's guaranteed but
neither is that right and so there is a
level people who are higher income
earners should probably not be going out
there trying to buy the duplex trying to
buy the four plex unless they want to do
what i said earlier and that's scale up
their own real estate business but if
it's like i'm gonna go and figure out a
duplex because i think that'll be a good
investment it's just you might as well
just like find people you know like and
trust put your money with them and it's
just
way better so you don't have to buy
another piece of real estate but i'd
love to take your money someday all
right you got my money all right
all right thankfully jack cannot invest
because he's not accredited
well then you get insurance on that but
there's going to be something that's
going to go wrong so please that that's
the one agreement i will give you money
but you cannot
we'll make a special fun just for you
and we'll go buy a duplex for you it'll
be great yeah we're going to get you a
duplex that's great awesome no more real
estate jack
all right thank you so much for coming
on really nice meeting you yeah you too
it's been fun yeah thank you uh guys
thank you so much for watching you got
to do us a quick favor though and
subscribe because uh it's it's half of
you watching are not subscribed which is
not okay it's totally free to do that's
just rude actually yeah i i don't know
why it's so easy just hit the little
button totally free we post once a week
so uh actually we we might even do a
bonus episode if you subscribe so that's
all you got to do and get your free
stock down below in the description
that's it it's worth all the way up to a
thousand dollars so thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
thank you that was awesome that was cool
perfect i love that all right good job
guys
oh jack you can't do anything right
are you still recording this yes
[Laughter]
that is good good job please keep that
in there